if car Saxon could see you now I know I
know right I mean when I when I got that
uh call to do this this voiceover for a
few episodes of this animated series and
I went in and um I said I said English
accent oh he's a bad guy yeah so he's
obviously so I did this and there was a
couple of more uh episodes later on I
thought nothing of it I thought that was
that was fun it was good great to do a
voiceover right no no and then two and a
half three years later I get a call
Disney would like you to come on board
for for something for a Star Wars
action
how does he fit it and not until I got
there you realize oh it's not gas accent
I don't know what you're thinking it's
not him and then it was revealed to me
there's a brand new character that
felony had written I've gone like
well thank goodness you didn't tell me
before him because I'm here now
um but yeah it's uh it was overwhelming
but two characters in the Star Wars
Universe oh yeah I never thought about
that two bubble heads
it must be cool too because I mean you
were you were in Rebels these are
characters that you have seen in the
animated form and then you're stepping
on set and you're like hey there's hair
there's Sabine weirdly enough you just
reminded me it's about the Marvel
Universe because I did um uh Punisher on
Marvel Max and then volstag and Thor
so I think maybe uh yeah I'm just I just
double I mean it's been a character I
just changed my looks chameleon nature
just throw me in there if you if you
want a Gravelly bad the guy voice then
just put me in one of my favorite things
that we saw from your character is just
kind of his like unique lightsaber
fighting style can you talk about
developing that yeah yeah because this
character is completely different from
somewhere that you're not used to it
it's not he doesn't adopt the sort of
foundations of the Kurosawa base movies
the the katana style Japanese fighting
um he's much more I say much more
aligned with uh Medieval sword sword
play so there is a completely different
style so when he goes out up against
Ahsoka quite a few like this there is a
clash of culture as well as and well
who wins I don't know I mean you know
but there is there is definitely uh uh
as a a huge sort of um a huge separation
from where their worlds are originate so
these two satellites crash and they got
this Dynamic that drives the stories
can you say we just learned his name his
name is balance
uh that's a pretty it's a pretty metal
last skull yes
spiking isn't it yeah there's a hint
there's a hint for us by the time it
reached the barrel of your gun
it costs one pound I also just want to
say RR was my it's one of the best
movies ever just there's something about
it reminds me of being a kid watching
the big epic movies when I was it just
is over this big epic story that brings
you in and the passions and the
loyalties and yeah and speaking of it
Roger mooley but I probably never get a
chicken vindaloo again if I try and get
a walk into a takeaway can never say no
no it's off no just frizzy off get a non
bread up the background auntie auntie
Lucas yeah yeah but what a thing to be
involved in Ray Stevenson and alfano
sakno
[Applause]
just from a total nerd standpoint you
step on this stage it's one of the best
I mean it's over I mean you walk in and
you feel like taking 10 steps back
because of this tsunami of love and like
oh my word and it's also uh
um the feeling of being so humble to it
because that's why I'm so happy that
they kept these things back to tease and
tease and wait and wait and then boom
because the fans deserve it it's like
you know it's that's what's bigger than
all of us is the fan base their
investment and so they deserve it and
what they gave us today was just like
you're just filming gratitude
[Music]